virginie efira re bonsoir
alors vous êtes belge mais à bruxelles
le 5 mai 1977 et vous êtes venu en
france pour payer plus d'impôts c'est ça
exactement
quand votre première vocation c'était
comedian et un jour fait un casting pour
rtl tvi et vous découvrez que le métier
d'animatrice vous plaît en tout cas
j'avais j'avais un gros problème à ce
moment-là de confiance par rapport à mon
désir premier qui était celui de jouer
il fallait bien le combler par quelque
chose je fasse quelque chose et c'est
totalement par hasard qu'on a proposé de
faire de la télévision au départ c'est
pas du tout prévu quoi leur première
émission à la télé belge en 97 c'est
megamix way l'émission pour ados ouais
vous aviez deux tresses
quelques rondeurs et des semelles
compensées à daloa nappe oui je sais pas
c'était assez évident à regarder mais
j'ai pas d'image du coup ça m'a obligé
quand même un peu à un peu à être drôle
oui c'est pascal et vous savez quoi non
certainement pas et puis un jour on vous
propose un casting pour m6 météo décalée
et deux semaines plus tard vous êtes
propulsé en prime time maîtresse de
cérémonie de la nouvelle star c'était
très très vite votre carrière là vous
mettez un peu de côté votre désir
d'enfant de faire de la comédie à ce
moment-là a complètement j'avais dans un
coin de ma tête mais je ne trouve pas ça
très conciliables quoi et donc il
fallait trouver un moment le moyen de le
faire mais du coup il fallait rompre
avec la avec l'animation voilà un jour
vous fait une apparition dans le camelot
ou fait off prime qui est une parodie de
vote mais c'est grâce à de nouveaux m6 à
ceux qui m'ont fait confiance là dessus
je me souviens thomas valentin qui est
le patron de m6 qui était venu me voir
jouer au théâtre alors que je vaux fin
fond de la belgique dans les ardennes
étaient venus jusque là il y avait un
vrai intérêt
ça leur servira est pas donc ils ont eu
tort parce que vous êtes parti c'est
vrai cheval sur canal ne faut pas être
sympa quand on est patron de chaîne
alors ensuite dû passer au cinéma il ya
deux succès au cinéma il ya l'amour
c'est mieux à deux de farrugia et le
mort il ya la chance de ma vie de
nicolas cuche alors vous avez déclaré la
nouvelle star je m'en foutais non mais
jamais une bêtise pareille en gros si
j'ai toujours mes impôts dix ans sur ce
que moi je faisais il n'avait pas un
intérêt non plus énorme ici il y avait
quand même il y avait des chanteurs qui
poussent des voiliers plutôt bien je
pense que julien doré ya que c'est la
huawei et puis avec le nord moi aussi
mais je traite jamais vraiment jamais eu
un beau coup et qu'il a fait puis avait
quand même un peu d'esprit je veux dire
mannequin il s'exprimait comment
s'exprime rarement la télévision dans
l'émission divertissement donc j'ai
toujours bien aimé c'est vraiment bien
aimé l'émission marc en revanche moi mes
petites interventions où il y avait plus
de chiffres que demorand quand même le
jeu des numéros de téléphone aussi ça me
semble pas d'un intérêt premier mais
c'est tout ça que j'ai dit mais la
nouvelle star nous faut pas du tout osé
déclarer je ne referai jamais animatrice
télé à moins d'avoir cinq enfants qui
n'ont rien à manger même 4
rabaisse le chiffre même on n'imaginait
pas votre souffrance nous à l'époque ah
mais j'ai aucune souffrance aucune
souffrance sauf qu'à un moment donné
quand on évolue on essaie d'accorder un
peu ce qu'on est à ce qu'on fait donc je
vais pas que je souffrais pas un moment
donné quand je me suis dit faut
affronter ce truc là c'est sûr que c'est
pas pour revenir en arrière ne construit
jamais la vie à plus d'image non non non
non non c'est moi j'ai toujours pensé
depuis le début que je l'aï vu à la
télévision et je lui ai dit que c'était
je pense que c'est la julia roberts
française
avec communiquer quand même son
enthousiasme et un moment j'avais pas
fait grand chose et ça a été quelque
chose d'assez important pour nous d'en
bas oui de ne pas sentir trop seul quoi
alors maintenant vous êtes dans le
cinéma mais il va falloir apprendre à
dire l'ambiance sur le tournage était
super oui j'ai des partenaires sans
midar voilà et on s'est vraiment avec le
metteur en scène entendu ont apporté
tous ensemble j'ai lu le scénario d'une
traite je me suis dit waouh il faut
absolument que je fasse fi
et non désolé je parle pas de ma vie
privée
oui comment ça va votre vie privée
extrêmement bien ah ouais je vous en
parle du tout en vacances la wii aux
maldives oui avec mon frère
et mon petit frère c'était génial oui
mais les maldives s'est passé pour aller
en coupe l'un à bombay passe quelque
chose partout soyeux reçoit hyères eux
allaient faire l'amour et tout ça est
donc si ça va ça je trouve ça terrible
oui que ce qui fait votre frère les
peintres away fed à pâtir figurative et
fait des choses très impressionnante
vous trouvez pas d animateur de télé un
supporter avec leurs questions lacombe
en existe vous je vous aime bien
regarder je sais mais on va voir vous
avez déclaré alors attention tout le
monde est là ardisson je les aime bien
c'est un mélange de plein de choses un
bon voilà c'est terrible c'est un vieux
qui a l'air encore jeune
il n'essaie pas de jouer aux branches et
il est branché un bon il est extrêmement
intelligent et cultivé
ce qui est assez rare à la télé
il a de l'humour il a su s'imposer au
cours du temps libre à dîner ce soir là
mais il ya toujours ce qu'on aimait non
là je vais bien tout va bien
quand j'étais ado ouais moi je me
souviens de toutes les émissions tout ça
j'étais déjà évidemment mais oui quand
on aime très fort des choses à cette
période là dans l'adolescence et tous
sont des choses qui passent elle aimait
déjà les vieux
heureusement
bon alors on nous verra le 23 décembre à
20h35 sur france 2 dans un téléfilm qui
s'appelle à la maison pour noël oui il
est produit par kader aoun que j'ai co
produit avec kader d'ailleurs mais c'est
grâce à vous j'ai rencontré d'ailleurs
il arrive avec un projet extrêmement
particulier de deux auteurs anglais avec
une écriture qui va très loin dans
l'absurde c'est je pense à sa faim moi
ça correspond humour que j'aime c'est
l'histoire d'une avocate super organisé
psychorigide et qu'ils rencontrent dans
la nuit de noël une collection de dingue
c'est ça oui oui oui ça va loin dans la
folie oui oui bon de les obsessionnels
en plus c'est quelqu'un qui est bardé de
certitudes et des idées un peu
définitive si on est en couple il faut
se marier si on fête noël ils font au
kindle bio on n'encourage pas la
mendicité est enfin là plein de petits
trucs comme ça un peu ballet chiante et
puis elle va tout perdre en une seule
nuit
son argent son statut et ses certitudes
ce qui est plutôt pas mal à la maison
pour noël donc voilà sur france 2
juillet
avec adel bencherif brown avec rachel
arditi avec jackie berroyer avec le sait
bien c'est très bien on voit que vous
êtes dans le coup mais je veux toujours
citer tout le monde du succès ouais
partie des trucs un ca meilleur film de
christian merret palmair
pas mal et oui elle c'est un boulot le
ch est bien et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de zinal habitudes abonnez vous il
m'était impossible eux